a multi-party system is normal you only
have a two-party system if there's a
repression it's not natural hi I'm
Alexis Garcia with Reason TV and our
guest today is well-known in libertarian
circles for his expertise on election
law you can basically say he's the guru
of third parties and ballot access
he's also the publisher and editor of
ballot access news I'm here with Richard
winger now Richard it's so great to talk
to you and you know I've heard you
introduced so many times as the walking
encyclopedia of election law how does
one become involved in that and why did
you start ballot access News this is one
of the things that anchors me being a
libertarian before the government got
involved in printing ballots we had
total freedom and we didn't have
government printed ballots until 1889
but parties mostly printed up ballots
and distributed them to anybody that
wanted and if you use the party print
about you're free to scratch off names
of people you didn't like and write in
somebody else but we had complete
freedom to run for office you can get
into the race the week before the
election
there is no filing fees no declarations
of candidacy no being thrown off of the
ballot because you made a tiny little
mistake and that's what freedom is there
were disadvantages just to that of
course but ever since the government
took it over they've been using it as a
tool of repression you know we really
pride ourselves on our democracy and our
freedom but is that the case when it
comes to actually running for office
there's so many ways in which the United
States is near the bottom of democracies
not just about ballot access and
treatment of small parties or the only
country in the world that won't let
people register to vote because in the
past they committed a crime now I'm not
saying all states do that but some still
do we're the only country in the world
where the adult citizens living in the
capital city have no voting
representation in the national
legislative body we're the only country
in the world that has a popular vote to
elect the chief executive but the person
who comes in second can still win the
election it's frustrating to me that
Americans don't have more awareness of
how
how many big problems there are and
we've seen in this cycle with two very
unpopular candidates we have a couple of
third party options that are really kind
of picking up traction what's it been
like this cycle for people like Gary
Johnson and Jill Stein well of course
both Gary Johnson and Jill Stein are
quite happy right now because they're
getting unparalleled publicity it's kind
of ironic in this country ballot access
for president for minor parties and
independents has been getting slowly
easier in fact the number of signatures
to get on the ballot in all the states
for president is now at the lowest level
as a percentage since 1936 which is
amazing really we keep working and
working to improve the laws and for
President were slowly succeeding but
ironically for Congress it's going the
other direction now here's the
Libertarian Party on the ballot in all
50 states for president but how about US
House of Representatives the whole
country votes on that too
and there's only about 1/4 of the
districts this year that will see a
libertarian on their ballot for US House
a little known fact is the ballot access
laws for Congress are much worse than
President and they're getting worse well
that's not interesting because I
actually worked on a Senate campaign in
Massachusetts and kind of saw firsthand
just the craziness when it comes to
getting signatures taking them to their
own individual towns to get certified it
just seems like even being part of the
party apparatus like the Republican or a
Democratic Party it was tough enough can
you talk a little bit about the cost
associated with not having that party
apparatus and how that it basically
creates a barrier to entry doesn't it
yes I'm really glad you mentioned
Massachusetts people in Massachusetts
have a high opinion of themselves in
their state and they should
Massachusetts is the birthplace of the
fight for independence really is but
Massachusetts year-after-year is the
only state where a majority of the US
House seats in November only have one
candidate on the ballot in 2014 they
have nine seats
and six of them there was only a
Democrat in the
allit in this year five of them all you
have a Democrat in the ballot and the
people Massachusetts they don't seem to
notice there's anything wrong and for
the legislature always over half the
seats only have one person in the ballot
it's because it's so hard to get on a
primary ballot in Massachusetts it's
easily the worst in the country other
states other than Massachusetts that you
would say are like really bad offender
Oh horrible the the absolute worst
ballot access law in the country is
Georgia for us house for an independent
or a minor party the law is so bad it's
73 years old and no minor party has ever
complied with it in 73 years and no
independent has complied with it since
1964 and while some states make it next
to impossible for independent candidates
to get on the ballot others like to
change their rules without notice this
happened to Gary Johnson in Ohio after
the Secretary of State threatened to
keep the Libertarian Party nominee off
the ballot and it's so maddening Ohio
law explicitly says people who use the
independent candidate petition procedure
put a substitution committee on the
petition so they can use stand-ins and
the Libertarian Party didn't know who
was running for president or vice
president until the end of May and I
wanted to get working on the petition
and it's too hard to be a party so they
did the independent petition so they put
stand-ins for president vice-president
and then they go to turn them in and the
Secretary of State acts like he never
heard of such a thing and the newspapers
didn't investigate if they had they
would have seen this has been used by
John Anderson in 1980 by the
Constitution party three years in a row
1996 2000 and 2004 by Ralph Nader in
2004 for Vice President like Oh the
Secretary of State did the Libertarians
a big favor by letting them use this
thing which has been used all along
they're so secure with the two-party
system why would they care if there's a
third option there's been unbelievable
hostility just in the last few months to
minor parties by certain states
reinterpreting their rules to make them
much worse
and doing it at the last minute so
there's no time for the parties to fight
back
there's been 13 people in history who
ran in major Party presidential
primaries and then they ran in the
general election as independence and for
a hundred years
we've heard we've had presidential
primary since 1912 for a hundred years
nobody had ever been kept off the
general election ballot as a minor party
or independent on the grounds that he or
she had run another and a major Party
presidential primary and then they did
that to Gary Johnson in Michigan
2012 well this year there's a guy named
rocky de la Fuente well he ran on a
bunch of Democratic presidential
primaries and now all of a sudden state
after state after state is telling him
hey you can't be in the Bell as an
independent because you ran in the
Democratic presidential primary even
though these are states that allowed it
before and why do you think that's
happening there's so much insecurity
there's so much fear when the country is
relaxed the ballot access laws get
better and we made huge gains in the
late 90s but every time this fear things
go backwards there was a lot of fear Oh
a terrible amount of backward movement
in the literally 30s when people were
afraid the Communist Party was getting
strong there really wasn't but people
didn't know that and state after state
made the ballot access laws in 1931 and
33 another bad period was 1969 1971 that
was because George Wallace shocked the
country when in 1968 he got 13% of the
vote well that was the first time
anybody had got over 2% outside the
major party since 1924 so it really was
revolutionary not in a good way not at
all and so that was the worst period for
making hostile changes in ballot access
laws right after him the
counter-argument to all this would be
but it should be hard to get on the
ballot because it shows that you're a
serious candidate and that you're able
to navigate government properly I mean
what is your rebuttal to that well if
everybody had to do these difficult
things that argument might
seem worth exploring but the truth is
it's not true the Democratic and
Republican Party has never had to
petition for itself to get a place in
the ballot every time once in a while
something goes wrong in one of the major
parties loses status as a qualified
party but every single time legislature
just changes the law like in Florida
it's really funny in 1931 they repealed
all means for new parties or independent
candidates to get on the ballot they
were mad because in 1928 the Communist
Party in the Socialist Party did rather
well in fact for both parties of all
things Florida it was their best state
in the presidential election then of
course they defined part is a group that
had polled 30% of the vote for some
statewide office in the previous
election well haha 1936 the Republicans
didn't get 30% for anything so in 1937
they reduced it to 15% the most recent
one was Virginia 1990 the law defined a
party is something that pulled 10% for
any statewide office in the last
election well in 1990 the only statewide
race up was US Senate and John Warner
was a Republican he was very popular and
the Democrats decided not to run anybody
against him too late
they're not gonna get 10% they go off
the ballot so the legislature was called
in the special session and said okay a
party is something that both 10% of
either of the last two elections they
always do that you mentioned a couple of
these instances where they changes the
rules last minute do you think that they
would ever try to do that to any of the
major party candidates because I know
there's been instances where Republicans
and Democrats don't get their stuff in
on time but they still end up on the
ballot
that's absolutely right every single
time the Democrats and Republicans have
been late to get on for president they
miss a deadline - everybody's human
they're always forgiven and they should
be forgiven
we shouldn't elevate form over substance
we got a free election after all but in
1964 the Democratic Party of Iowa was
late certifying Lyndon Johnson in 1988
both major parties were late in
Deanna in 2008 they were both laid in
Texas so much I just let it slide yes
and this year you probably read
technically the Republican Party
Minnesota didn't do all the paperwork
right to certify their presidential
electors in Minnesota but the Minnesota
Supreme Court just said nevermind so how
does limonene ballot access affect our
democracy and what can be done to change
the status quo well we have one of the
lowest turnout rates of any free country
in the world you know in Canada every
district for House of Commons in the
2015 election have at least five parties
on the ballot because in Canada ballot
access is easy and equal you can run for
House of Commons in Canada with a
hundred signatures and a thousand
dollars and in Britain it's only ten
signatures and 500 pounds and so Britain
also typically the typical district has
six candidates and it doesn't crowd the
ballot because I feel like that's a big
concern people always talk about it's
like well there's just gonna be too many
names that's ridiculous
you know most restaurants have menus
that are you know way more choices but
somehow people still cope richer thank
you so much for talking with us today
Oh Alexis thank you so much I enjoyed it
and we've been talking to Richard winger
with ballot access news for a reason TV
I'm Alexis Garcia
you